you know that visualpolitik is one of
the few political channels that pays a
lot of attention to latin america one of
the least covered regions in the world
perhaps that is why many of you have
often asked us to talk more about latin
america well
we've got a solution
[Music]
we're proud to present latam politik a
newsletter that we have prepared
together with geopolitical consulting
firm
perch perspectives if you subscribe
every month you will receive
12 newsletters with the best information
and analysis
on latin america to keep you up to date
and better understand everything that is
happening in this region the cost
you can subscribe for less than 35 cents
per newsletter
less than a small taco or a donut a week
in return
you'll be kept up to date on all major
happenings in the region and better
understand
all the possible implications in
addition all of you who support us at
patreon level four and five
will receive latin politic at zero cost
you can find all the info
at latimpolitik.com
[Music]
coronavirus pandemic confinement
vaccination words
that until recently were strange and yet
have become part of our everyday
vocabulary
yes the world has changed but my friends
what hasn't changed is that
a picture is still worth a thousand
words take a look at this graph
as you can see israel has become the
global role model for its covet 19
vaccination campaigns to give you an
idea
at the beginning of february 2021 when
the subject of vaccines was still taboo
due to
lack of distribution in most developed
countries 4 out of 10
israelis had already received at least
one dose of vaccine against sars cove
too but that's not all by that time more
than one-fifth of the population was
already fully immunized thanks to
vaccines we
are talking about almost 2 million
people in a country with a population
of less than 10 million
however israel's fight against the
coronavirus is proving to be far more
complicated than these figures indicate
why well basically because a part of the
population is reluctant to follow some
of the guidelines
set by the health authorities israel's
leaders clashed with ultra orthodox over
covet 19 lockdowns
vaccines wall street journal
ultra-orthodox jews place the torah the
text that contains the laws of the
jewish religion above all
other aspects of daily life so now the
questions that come up are what are the
religious implications for this
community
in their day-to-day lives why are they
reluctant to comply with the measures
put in place to fight the coronavirus
and perhaps the most important question
of all
what other problems arise for the state
of israel that this community
that of the ultra-orthodox jews is
becoming larger and larger and take note
dear friends because this is one of the
great challenges facing the hebrew
nation so today on visualpolitik we are
going to answer all these questions but
first
let's take a look at a bit of history
those who tremble before god
israel is the only country in the world
in which judaism is the majority
religion amongst its population 80
of its citizens profess the jewish
religion so far no surprises right but
the point is that not all jews are the
same within judaism there are different
branches
branches that differ from each other
according to the degree of intensity
with which their followers
live their religion most of the jews of
israel are hiloni or
secular in fact we cannot forget that
israel is a state created mainly by
people with socialist ideals who
yes were obviously jewish but what they
established was precisely a secular
state and today the population of israel
is still mostly like that
jews who practice some of their
religious practices and traditions and
others
who don't come on that happens in any
other western country with a range of
[Music]
religions
just as there are jews whose religion
has hardly any influence
at the other extreme we find the
ultra-orthodox jews
they are the so-called haredim which in
hebrew means those who tremble before
god but the fact that there is a
minority group in a country that places
the jewish law the torah at the centre
of their lives would have little
importance if it were not
friends because there are more and more
of them the ultra-orthodox population is
growing and the political parties
representing the haredim have more and
more presence in israeli political life
to the point of being crucial and the
question is
how did the secular state of israel come
to find itself in this situation well
for that we have to travel to the middle
of the 20th century precisely to the
very origin of the state of israel
in 1948 david ben-gurion proclaimed the
independence of the state of israel and
became its first prime minister one of
his first decisions was to accept the
request of the rabbis to rebuild the
legendary yeshivat of europe
in israel these were the academies of
torah and talmud study that had been
destroyed during the holocaust
israel's political leaders saw
ultra-orthodox judaism as an anachronism
that would soon disappear
even so they saw fit to protect
traditions that were already in danger
of extinction
[Music]
the yeshevat had always been a place
reserved for bright students
let's say that only the best academic
minds were dedicated exclusively to the
study of the torah so what ben gurion
thought was that
there would be about 400 yeshua students
and since there were not many he granted
them the privilege of being exempt from
military service
what he didn't count on was that the
rabbis would encourage every heredi to
enter
rabbinic schools which is exactly what
they did
currently there are more than 100 000
heredity men who do not
work and spend their days studying the
torah and you may be wondering but if
they don't work
then how do they support themselves well
i could answer for you but perhaps it's
better to look at what jakov litzman who
is currently the leader of one of the
main ultra-orthodox political parties
and who is also the current minister of
housing
said a few years ago a ready lawmaker
men
need not work wives and state allowances
can pay the bills
hurrats that's exactly what he said in
fact governments in which the hereditary
parties have participated have been
dedicated to extending more and more
benefits for large families and
subsidies to pay for rabbinic school
students
as a result israel allocates some 300
million dollars of its budget each year
to yeshivat alone and of course the
result of all this is that heredi men
know a lot about their holy books but
very little about the job market
as you can see half of her ready men do
not work and it is women who are
increasingly joining the labour market
however the jobs to which ultra-orthodox
people usually have access are more
precarious because from a young age they
are offered a religious training
not one aimed at carrying out a
profession what's more haradim cannot
accept just any job they must be jobs
that separate men's and women's
positions where the canteen serves
kosher food and where the sabbath is
observed
so the life of the average heritage
woman has become one challenge after
another in addition to financially
supporting the family with their jobs
outside the home
inside the home the family burden also
falls on the woman and of course
ultra-orthodox families are quite large
they have six or seven children as
opposed to two for the average
non-religious family
in fact this explains why the proportion
of the hereditary among the israeli
population has increased
by 30 percent in just 10 years from 10
in 2009 to 13 in 2020
[Music]
by the year 2065 the ultra-orthodox
jewish community
is expected to represent at least
one-third of the country's population as
it stands today approximately 25 percent
of the first graders in elementary
school belong to ultra-orthodox families
even though haredim are only 13
of the total population and my friends
that's how things were when the
coronavirus arrived listen up
[Music]
nephesh
the coronavirus has taken its toll on
israeli's ultra-orthodox community it
accounts for one-third of all kovit-19
infections in the country and the truth
is that it's not easy to determine
whether it was due to vulnerability or
directly due to irresponsibility because
the mainstream and social media keep
circulating photos and videos of large
crowds of haradim praying close together
without any social distancing and
ignoring the ban on gatherings of more
than 10 people as if we were in 2019
wow april 2nd 2020 israeli health
minister ultra orthodox
positive for coronavirus herald as you
can imagine
most of the israeli population is
outraged with the behavior of the
ultra-orthodox community
keep in mind that in march 2020 when the
coronavirus broke out they closed all
educational institutions while yeshivat
and synagogues continued to operate
because haradim said that the torah
protects and saves in the end the rabbis
themselves had to recognize
that the torah is very good for the soul
but to protect one's health
a mask and social distancing are better
of course there is always the occasional
free spirit
ultra orthodox rabbi tells followers
covet vaccine
can turn people gay independent yes it's
true that under normal circumstances
these words would be nothing more than
an anecdote albeit a barbaric one but at
the end of the day an isolated case
however what is important is to consider
the damage done by a rabbi spreading
fake news among the ultra-orthodox
community
[Music]
the influence exercised by the rabbis
over haradine is brutal they are
forbidden for example to own televisions
or radios they are allowed to buy cell
phones but as this chart shows accessing
the internet
is another matter all this has created
an obstacle for public health
recommendations to reach this part of
the population many how redeem do not
receive the text messages notifying them
that they have been in contact with a
coveted positive person and obviously
once a heredity is infected
it is very easy for the disease to
spread remember what we said before
large families few economic resources it
is not hard to imagine that many of the
ultra-orthodox families
live in overcrowded homes not to mention
that many are not willing to give up
religious celebrations
[Music]
in january 2021 thousands of people
attended the mass funeral of rabbi david
solovicic which provoked the anger of
the current minister of defense
benny gantz this is what unequal
enforcement looks like
millions of families and children are
locked in their homes and abide by the
rules
while thousands of ultra-orthodox crowds
at the funeral most of them even without
masks
we will not agree to the continuation of
an ineffective closure either
they close to everyone or they open to
everyone the days of indulgence are over
minister of defense benny gans the truth
is that the authorities
are afraid to act because every time
police forces have been sent against the
ultra-orthodox crowds they have
literally been met with stones not to
mention the political influence
and then there is the vaccination
campaign you have already seen that
israel became the international
benchmark for how to do things
however that has not been easy either
health minister wants 24 7 vaccinations
but top rabbis said to oppose on shabbat
times of israel in the end the
minister's judgment prevailed as you
would expect right but he had to invoke
the picoac
fish a principle of jewish law according
to which the preservation of human life
overrides practically every other
religious rule but hold on a minute
because the rabbis have come out
swinging
[Music]
first they said that the situation was
not serious enough to invoke the pikachu
fish
nah it's just a little pandemic then
later they changed their strategy they
went on to say that okay there was no
problem vaccinating on the sabbath but
at first
it had to be demonstrated that the
vaccine was being administered 24 6.
that is 24 hours a day during the rest
of the days of the week before starting
to do it on the sabbath
finally they came out with a statement
that what cannot be done on the sabbath
is to record the vaccinated patient's
data
or drive to the vaccination center
fortunately for israelis the government
has taken the coronavirus seriously and
the truth is that their efforts paid off
by mid february 2021
in areas where the hereditary population
is concentrated 72 percent of people
over 60 had been immunized just eight
percent below the national average for
that age group so in this matter at
least
danger has been avoided even so the
issue of the sabbath continues to be a
talking point in israeli politics and it
is not the only controversial issue
let's take a look
the key to the nested
the ultra-orthodox jews never wanted the
creation of the state of israel for
haradim zionism and submitting to civil
authorities is a kind of heresy so what
did ben gurion do
well the same as today's politicians he
sought the support of the ultra-orthodox
rabbis for an independent state of
israel and ben-gurion achieved this by
promising them that public services
would not operate on the sabbath the
most obvious result is seen in the
public transportation for more than 70
years
buses and trains have not run in most of
israel from sundown on friday until
saturday night and of course as you can
imagine an overwhelming majority of the
israeli population is sick to death of
the weekend arriving and realizing all
the things that they can't do
because of the sabbath
[Music]
and so it continued until the end of
2019 when we can see new stories
like this buses overflow as tel aviv
launches public transportation on
shabbat times of israel the initiative
has been a success and has been copied
by other cities however it remains to be
seen whether it will be maintained over
time because the financing of local
bodies depends on the ministry of the
interior and so far harodim have
benefited from the fact that
in the last two years israel has not had
a solid government after going to the
polls
up to three times march 23rd will be the
fourth the truth is that the pressure
exerted by the ultra-orthodox community
bothers israeli citizens a lot
even a good part of the right-wing
voters but the problem is that the
support of the hereditaries is often
vital to former government
[Music]
israel is a parliamentary democracy in
which its prime minister is
elected by a majority of the knesset
it's a legislative assembly therefore
the support of 61 of the 120 members of
the knesset is required for 30 years no
political party has gained more than 40
representatives
that means massive coalition governments
have to be formed in some cases
of almost 30 ministries
[Music]
you know you've got to keep all the
coalition parties happy therefore
getting the support of the
ultra-orthodox parties to form a
government is very tempting
since between the two parties
representing haradine they usually get
about 15 parliamentarians that's 15
seats closer to 61. so after march 23rd
we will see if the public transportation
on the sabbath is here to stay and if
this is already somewhat controversial
hold on a moment because there is
another
issue that outrages israelis even more
military service in israel is compulsory
for all citizens
in fact israel is one of only nine
countries in the world where women also
carry out military service
even wonder woman has done military
service okay not wonder woman but gal
gadot which provoked such curious news
stories as this one
wonder woman banned in lebanon because
lead actress
is israeli cnn the fact is that all
israeli citizens perform military
service all
no the religious community of unyielding
haradim resists conscription now
and always well actually the
ultra-orthodox jews and also the israeli
arabs because call me crazy but it seems
to me that no matter how much relations
between israel and other arab countries
have improved israel does not look
favorably on giving military training to
its arab population but the fact that
very few haradim accepts the 2.5 years
of military service for men and two
years for women bothers the majority of
israeli citizens who have to interrupt
their own studies or professional
development to serve the state as you
can imagine maintaining this exemption
is one of the red lines of the heredi
parties you know the torah protects and
serves
the problem haradim have is that the
israeli supreme court has already
declared on two occasions that laws
exempting ultra-orthodox jews from
military service are
unconstitutional because they are
discriminatory so the supreme court has
opened a temporary
deadline for a non-discriminatory
regulation to be developed
the aim is to make the obligation to
incorporate the hereditary community
into the military service progressive
and respecting all their particularities
you know
kosher food that men do not share spaces
with women however as we told you before
israel has not had a solid government
for two years and the deadline has run
out
the latest information is that a final
extension has been requested
a.g requests universal idf draft apply
to heredi sector on july 6th
jerusalem post in short this issue has
every chance of being one of the main
topics on the negotiating table of the
next israeli government or governments
we will keep an eye on this issue at
visualpolitik and we will also tell you
more about the challenges this community
poses for the future of the state of
israel but now the question is over to
you do you think israel will end up
creating a heredit battalion or will
this group continue to join the army in
drips and traps will the state of israel
be able to withstand the pressure of a
growing population that refuses to work
and depends on the public coffers for
their livelihood leave us your answer in
the comments and if you found this video
interesting then please give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe to
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done so all the best
i'll see you next time if you want to
learn more about politics and world
affairs and hear some more of my lovely
voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcatcher